hey guys how's it going happy tech
Tuesday so today we're gonna be chatting
about the new iphone 7 pro now this
rumor sort of popped up the past couple
of days and I was reading about it
yesterday and it was getting really
really excited so it looks like from
some of the things that I've read the
people are speculating that there's
gonna be an iphone 7 pro an iPhone 7
plus and an iPhone 7 I want to say basic
but that's not what they're gonna be
calling it but you should cuz that would
be awesome the iPhone 7 basic Hey look
at my iPhone 7 basic I'm just a basic
iPhone buying basic person so the big
announcement will be on March 21st so
then we'll actually find out what is
going to be announced and what it'll be
released let's just hop right into some
of the iphone 7 pro rumors Apple is
launching an iphone 7 pro and the
Internet is going crazy well they say
the Internet I don't who does that
encompass because that doesn't encompass
everyone because not every single person
on the Internet
is going crazy I mean I'm going crazy
but we've already established that I am
crazy and I love Apple a lot some of you
guys might have seen that one video I'm
blanking on the dudes name but he does
like these crazy ridiculous terrible
illustrations and like Microsoft Paint
and pretty much just making it put of
everybody who gets hyped up about
Samsung and Apple phones and he called
me out for being one of the first people
in line and everyone's like oh you got
roasted I was like dude I mean I slept
outside for three days for a phone yeah
I think I think I know what I'm doing
I'm clearly not insane
so I thought the video was really funny
so for anyone who thought I was offended
I thought it was hilarious but moving
right along to exactly what he was
talking about the Internet is going
crazy over an iphone 7 pro I think this
is kind of crazy if they do decide to do
three different models of the same phone
if it really is only the iPhone 6 and
iPhone 6 plus just an upgraded version
of that the iPhone 7 then the iphone 7
pro will be sort of the big up
okay so we're only a week away from the
rumored release of the new iPhone 5se
which I think they've already
established that it's going to be called
the iPhone se and not the five which
would be extremely silly let's call the
new iPhone whatever that is not a five
they've already messed up their
numbering sequences so it really at this
point I would not be surprised if they
call it the iPhone 5se which I don't
think they should the vineyard news the
iPhone 7 iPhone 7 plus but word on the
street is we'll be getting an iphone 7
pro let's just click through and see
where this takes us March 2 it's March 8
okay we've already talked about this for
the dual lens which will basically have
two rear facing cameras it'll allow you
to take better sharper pics in low-light
and get rid of the slight protrusion
from the lens the back of your phone
show of hands of anybody who does not
use a case on your iPhone because it
slips right out of my hand I had this
for two seconds when I first got it
cracked
so they're saying Apple can't produce
the camera models in enough quantity so
it'll create a third smartphone just to
get the technology to the market to make
more limited quantities so it's kind of
interesting so basically they're saying
that they're not gonna be able to get
enough of the dual cameras so hey let's
just make three phones throw in the
better camera in the iphone 7 pro make
you guys pay more for it which we're
going to do and then upgrade those other
two phones which would essentially be a
better version of the six right here
we know we're suckers let's see what
else we can find dual lens camera will
be introducing Evan Sutton yes we know
this was March 7 so this was yesterday
this patent outlines a dual camera
system that consists of one standard
wide angle lens similar to what's in the
iPhone today in a second telephoto lens
capturing zoomed in photos both lenses
can be used simultaneously to take two
separate photos when capturing video
photo users able to transition between
both lenses seamlessly packing one spot
but what's wrong about this is that
what's interesting between the two
cameras to get a zoomed in view and one
that's not something like what the LG g5
does this will actually let you use both
of those camera modules the zoomed in
one named
at the same time and Apple outlines the
photo taking opportunity a child's
birthday party a parent could capture a
video over the moment before the candle
in the cake are blown out using the
standard wide-angle iPhone camera and
then tap on the screen to open a
split-screen view and activate the
telephoto lens for a close-up portrait
shot of the exact moment the candles are
blown out that's cool I'm into that
Kourtney the patent and both cameras are
able to be used separately that'll be
really interesting so let's do some
comparisons and see if we can figure out
how big the iphone 7 pro might be iphone
6s iphone 6s plus so if you were to be
maybe iPhone 7 what color do we want the
iPhone 7 to be that's alright are you
ready
iPhone 7 hi John juicy iPhone 7 while
I'm making it this is looking real good
like I'm taking this very seriously I
think it's good enough you guys get a
point like it's not real so guys my
puppy has a cola on his head are you do
wait little baby is a cone so that is
what I think the Ibis pro whatever it's
gonna be called I think it'll be that
big for sure I'm not really quite sure
the dimensions of it but it's gonna look
nice
absolutely obsessive you guys are
looking for really high quality Apple
images if you go to apple.com slash PR
they have tons of info and really great
high quality photos I thought this was
interesting from Gizmodo every Apple
product that is probably in the works
for anjaii phone already been
established the iPad air 3 do people
even talk about the iPad pro anymore I
think for illustrators the iPad pro is
fantastic but if you're not really doing
illustration or anything crazy it's a
little big Apple watch - I love my Apple
watch I don't really use my Apple watch
as necessarily a SmartWatch I use it for
the calendar I use it to read my
messages and I use it to actually tell
time I don't really use many of the
other apps so I don't know about you
guys but if you do let me know some of
your favorite Apple watch apps I'm sure
there are some awesome ones but I
don't really use them that often iPhone
7 optical image stabilization killer
zoom it could have dual cameras I think
we've already decided that and one of
the huge things which was a huge debate
in one of the previous videos that I
made is will Apple remove the headphone
jack they do have three versions of the
iPhone 7 the iphone 7 pro maybe
potentially would be the one that they
removed the headphone jack and the
iPhone 7 plus and the iPhone 7 basic
which was what we're gonna or just gonna
call it that those ones may still have
the headphone jacks since it could be
just an upgraded version of the six and
a pro could sort of be the whole new
version of the iPhone 7 so that's what
I'm kind of thinking because I don't
think people are ready for fully
bluetooth headsets I don't think they
are even if there are lightning cable
adapters I still don't think people are
ready to think that might be a little
too soon Apple TV for holy moly you just
came out with another one a new
streaming service that could cost 30 to
40 dollars a month that's a lot so that
would actually be interesting if you
were able to watch local channels like
ABC CBS and Fox but still $40 a month I
don't know if that's not sure that
better include Apple music that's all
I'm saying
not a question for you guys who uses
Apple music anybody next up iPad Mini 5
speculated to be thinner than a thinner
really I mean honestly what you can only
make these things so thin until it
completely disappears until you just
have a freaking contact input so can we
just skip to that because I'm ready just
put the contacts into my eyes let me
just let me just be not a human any
longer I feel like the iPad Mini 5
definitely should have 3d touch not that
anybody uses it I really hardly ever use
it except when I accidentally fetch it
too hard like box everything is going
crazy I'm accidentally setting pictures
and things are just going Oh everywhere
what have we got anything it's too early
to guests yeah it's definitely way too
early I mean I feel like iOS 9 just came
out new MacBook with sky like chips
faster and more powerful anyway moving
right along love stuff some more things
about the iphone 7 pro because this is
this is what us is what homie wants to
know let's see what kind of images we've
got what the hell's that this is like a
what you're drunk go home this is like a
mini a mini MacBook iPhone 7 evolution
every dimension and Sheeran I'm into
that that's so thin like I cannot get
over that this is interesting
will hmm I wondered it's a lot of
capability of doing 3d that's hideous
this just this this is I mean it looks
cool but I really don't think Apple is
gonna do away with any of the buttons
yet because I feel like they put so much
into the touch ID that they're not ready
to sort of do away with that and if this
is the full screen where are you gonna
put the touch ID that's just I'm that's
disgusting and Apple is never gonna do
the light up on the back of the phone
and if they do I'm gonna be extremely
upset because you could not find any
more ways to waste any more battery life
all we want is to have a longer battery
life my phone is the size of my body and
I can't even go a whole day with my
phone being charged what the hell is
this what is this what it looks like one
of the Apple TV remotes are you on drugs
that does that's not right it's so
skinny I actually really do like the
colored iPhones I thought that was a
really good idea oh hey look at my clear
iphone look what I've got do you like it
looks good this is my new iPhone it's
invisible thank you guys so much for
watching I will see you in my next video
happy tech Tuesday let me know in the
comments below
any of the things I asked you in this
video at this point I don't even
remember what are you most looking
forward to in the new iPhone what do you
think about the lack of a headphone jack
and what do you think that Apple will be
announcing on March 21st at their big
announcement I'll see you guys later
I'm gonna go out at this video now honey
I am very very sorry to do this you
tonight just hold on we're going home